i'm charles payne i'm kat timf i'm
stuart varney and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday march 16th 2022 and lisa brady
it's like a flashback to 2015 a familiar
debate over iran's nuclear program but
this time there's a russian twist i just
think in the middle everything is
happening in ukraine
sort of the irony that we're relying on
the russians to broker a deal with iran
i think that speaks volumes about how
bad this deal really is
i'm dave anthony
the attack russia started in ukraine
could mean the end of our alliance in
space
we just can't deal with russians anymore
we can't trust them
based upon everything that's going on
i'm liz peek i've got the final word on
the fox news rundown
[Music]
while russia has been bombing ukraine
the u.s has been at the table with
russia as part of indirect nuclear talks
with iran aimed at restoring the 2015
multi-nation deal that president trump
pulled the u.s out of nearly four years
ago we continue to believe that it is
profoundly in our national interest to
see to it that iran is permanently and
verifiably barred from obtaining a
nuclear weapon state department
spokesman ned price says the hope is to
complete a mutual return to compliance
with the joint comprehensive plan of
action or jcpoa as it's known in short
order but some of the same questions
that dogs the original deal persist
including just how verifiable iran's
nuclear activities are and how long any
deal really prevents it from obtaining
nuclear weapons if sunset provisions are
included add to that an iranian missile
strike last weekend in northern iraq
landing near a u.s consulate iran's
revolutionary guard claiming it was
targeting an israeli strategic center
after israel killed two of its members
in syria deputy secretary of state wendy
sherman telling fox news sunday iran's
malign behavior in the middle east does
need to be addressed after a nuclear
deal you know we are very concerned
about what iran is doing but imagine
these iranians with a nuclear weapon
russia threw a wrench into the talks
last week demanding that future trade
deals with iran would have immunity from
sanctions the state department said
tuesday that a nuclear deal won't be an
escape hatch from sanctions over the war
in ukraine well we know that the
russians are in close coordination with
the e3's negotiations with iran texas
republican congressman michael mccall is
ranking member of the house foreign
affairs committee we also know that the
iranian officials visited moscow
recently to meet with russian officials
about this iran deal i just think in the
middle of everything that's happening in
ukraine sort of the irony that we're
relying on the russians to broker a deal
with iran
i think that speaks volumes about how
bad this deal really is
should russia have been
kicked out of these talks um when the
invasion began or is the thinking that
it's not possible to have an iran deal
without them
i think russia is so involved in this
deal would be very difficult to reach a
deal without them they're the only
country that has any leverage over iran
which is why they're sitting at the
table
which is why i think return to the jcpoa
was was a mistake because we're having
to rely on now the russians to get to a
deal that we think they're going to tell
us is a good deal when in fact it's
going back to the 2015 deal and now on a
shorter timetable with the sunset
provisions in there that will guarantee
a nuclear iran within one to two years
yeah i wanted to ask you about that 2015
deal because part of former president
trump's argument was that iran
already wasn't living up to that deal
before he pulled the us out of it i mean
is there any reason to believe it would
be any different now
it's a trust issue and i don't think we
can really trust them
they've increased their enrichment up to
60 percent they can probably flip it to
90 which is enough to make a bomb with
in a matter of a year they already have
short-range missiles and for god's sakes
they just bombed iraq in a very
aggressive invasion with their missiles
yesterday almost hitting a u.s consulate
i mean you can't make this stuff up i
mean we're actually negotiating with
people
that are you know creating the biggest
humanitarian crisis invasion since world
war ii
that's russia and then we're dealing
with iran that just fired missiles
i don't know if this is a
just pure naivete or just outright
stupidity but i just don't understand
the foreign policy strategy
what about the argument that
some transparency
is better
than what we get without a deal that at
least the un's nuclear watchdog can have
greater access to see what iran is doing
bearing in mind that it's never perfect
access
right i think we do want to continue to
have inspections with greater
transparency and certainly you know the
any time anywhere inspections made sense
to me but that's not what we have you
know right now if they would agree to do
an uh peaceful nuclear energy program
which is at the 3.67
enrichment we'd be having a different
discussion but that's not what they want
they want a glide path to have a nuclear
bomb in a matter of years and they're
also demanding that the restrictions are
placed on the irgc which is their
terrorist arm those foreign terrorist
organizations designations be lifted on
what is very clearly a terrorist
organization
throughout the middle east i just
returned from israel a couple weeks ago
talking to prime minister bennett's and
with former prime minister
netanyahu the entire knesset in israel
is against this deal and i think we owe
some deference to our
ally in the neighborhood in the middle
east and our partner if they think it's
a bad deal that really is a strong
statement
i remember the former prime minister
netanyahu used to hold up charts at the
u.n showing just how close iran was
to
having a nuclear weapon
what did he tell you on this recent trip
i mean how much closer is that time
frame now because you're mentioning in a
matter of years but he seemed to think
it was much sooner in terms of their
breakout time frame
well that's right prime minister
netanyahu is very clear that this is
even worse than the 2015 deal because
they have made so much
further progress then i think he made a
very strong case to our delegation
that the united states needs to stand
with israel in opposition
when you're negotiating partners of
russia who's invaded ukraine and iran
who's just fired missiles at your
consulate uh in iraq i just find that
doesn't go without the attention from
the united states congress and also
under the iran nuclear
agreement review act that we passed in
2015 it requires that this plan or this
deal must be submitted to congress
before any sanctions are lifted and it
also requires a vote from congress i've
gotten some information that i think
they're going to try to get around that
by saying that congress has already
agreed to the jcpoa and they're simply
just getting back in it therefore
avoiding any vote by the united states
congress
almost every republican senator signed a
letter warning the administration
that you know it appears they're ready
to give away the store in essence on
this agreement
if you had to name a number one concern
because we've talked about a lot of
concerns with the potential deal already
but what's really the number one concern
in your mind
that you could have the largest state
sponsor of terror with a nuclear weapon
within
a matter of one to two years and uh this
will create an arms race in the middle
east as we look at the events in ukraine
largest invasion since world war ii on
the european continent you couple that
with a chance of a nuclear armageddon in
the middle east i can't think of two
worse scenarios
one of the criticisms of the original
nuclear deal is that it did not hold
iran accountable
for sponsoring terrorism or any other
bad deeds if you will
they purposely
kind of didn't include that it was like
the obama administration didn't want to
muddy the waters on trying to reach a
deal just focusing on on the main issue
in their mind being the nuclear issue
has that strategy changed at all with
this administration has it even been put
on the table talk of any accountability
for sponsoring terrorism
no no it's not on the table and i was
basically told by the negotiators that
it couldn't be on the table because iran
would never they view that as a very
separate issue from their nuclear
program
and this is you know the uh from lebanon
with hezbollah to hamas and the gaza to
the houthi rebels uh in yemen and the
shia process been hitting iraq and syria
and there are forces there you know as
well but that is a non-starter with the
iranians in this deal
which also signifies why it's it's not a
good one
does the ukraine crisis
help to drive home
the need to make sure iran
never gets a nuclear weapon because
facing a nuclear-armed russia
really complicates the ukraine situation
i mean have you heard or sensed any
movement in the iran debate because of
that
you know i i know russia is making some
demands that we couldn't possibly meet
as you mentioned on the trade sanctions
and if it fell apart i think that would
be a positive thing but you know you're
seeing this sort of unholy alliance
really it's been there but it's really
starting to come together
and formalize between president xi and
putin
and iran and i would throw north korea
in that equation
as well and that's going to be the great
geopolitical
conflict that we're in right now
is there any form
of an iran nuclear deal
that you think would be acceptable to
republicans in in congress
that's a great question i think if they
would agree to deal with we would give
them enriched uranium at 3.67 for their
peaceful nuclear energy program or if
they would agree not to have sunset
provisions and have any time anywhere
inspections at 3.67 percent if they're
really serious about it being for a
peaceful nuclear energy program that
should be acceptable to them but the
problem is the whole premise of that is
that that's not what they're pursuing
it's not just a peaceful nuclear energy
program it is to become a nuclear power
and once the country is a nuclear power
it's very difficult to take it away from
them
well 49 out of 50 senate republicans are
vowing to reverse a deal that weakens
sanctions or makes it harder to confront
iran's support of terrorism for instance
do you think though that reversal is
only possible if republicans take back
control of congress or
is this an issue where some democrats
share your concerns
well i think two things on that one is
uh yeah you're right this would have to
be a veto proof majority vote and um
you're not going to find that in this
congress
and also the administration is going to
make the argument
that the iran nuclear agreement review
act doesn't apply
which would require a vote because
they've already we've already approved
the jcu poa itself
and so they're finding a legal argument
to get around that congressional vote by
the american people on something of this
magnitude
possibly if we get the majority back and
and we can reverse that legal
decision that we could have a vote on it
but that seems unlikely
it feels like this whole issue of iran
has been
kind of flying a little under the radar
uh recently especially because of the
ukraine crisis
what is
your message to the american people
about it what would your message be
well the timing is very
odd and awkward the negotiators and i
met with before they went to vienna and
this is all happening in the middle of
the russian invasion of ukraine
i would just argue to the american
people
this administration is once again going
down the road of appeasement
and that always invites aggression and
hostilities and that's why you're seeing
i think in large part
you know this uh
crimes against humanity situation in
ukraine and that's why you're seeing the
ayatollahs team going to moscow to meet
with the russians who are brokering this
deal that doesn't signal why this is not
a good deal i don't know what does
and just you know that's why you know
china's looking at an invasion of taiwan
um
you know it's a uh premise that goes
back to my dad's war the world war ii
and
you know chamberlain and hitler you know
churchill came in and talked about you
know appeasement invites aggression and
reagan talked about strength at peace
through strength and
i think those are historical actions are
still true today
texas republican congressman michael
mccall we appreciate your time
well thanks so much for having me
[Music]
this is liz peek with your fox news
commentary coming up
mark vande high made history this week
he has been in space longer than any
other american 341 days breaking fellow
astronaut scott kelly's record by one
day and he'll be there two more weeks
though there was some concern about his
return
because russia is giving vanda a ride
home and there is tension over its
ukraine invasion
the head of russia's space agency
suggested they could just leave him
there but nasa says no way i can tell
you for sure mark is coming home on that
soyuz
we are in communication with our russian
colleagues there's no fuzz on that
international space station program
director joel montelbano says the joint
operation with the russians continues to
go well despite the war in ukraine but
for how much longer our space program is
going great homer hickam is a former
nasa engineer and author of many books
including the memoirs rocket boys and
don't blow yourself up we're in kind of
the new golden age of
space with spacex and blue origin and
ula it's the russians that are in
trouble whether they know it or not
well we
have been dealing with them for decades
going back to when you were working at
nasa on the international space station
you helped set up the partnership with
russia correct
i did i had just finished
another international space flight with
the japanese i'd spent a couple of years
over in japan training the japanese for
what was called space lab j
training the first japanese astronauts
and we flew in 1992
and that was about the same time that
the vice president gore
i would say six to nine months later
after slj flew decided that the russians
should be part of the of our space
station we had one called space station
freedom that ronald reagan started
we hadn't launched anything we were
still building some modules and
vice president gore
decided that it would be a really good
idea to bring the russians in
since the soviet union had fallen and
there was some worry that their
engineers might go work for north korea
or iraq or iran well you probably had to
build trust too i mean we we were in the
cold war for decades with the soviets so
first of all you have to build trust and
that had to be the hardest thing at
first anyway right
well yeah i mean you know what was
interesting for me uh of course i'm kind
of famous for seeing sputnik fly over in
1957 when i lived in west virginia and
it prompted me to ultimately build a
whole bunch of rockets homemade rockets
go to the national science fair and then
become an engineer
so
that story was you know rocket boys and
then the movie october sky right so here
i am sitting across from the table
with the men who had actually launched
sputnik um our
engineers and scientists from the old
apollo days had long since retired but
in russia those men were still there so
that was very very interesting to me to
start talking to them they were very
gruff
very unhappy having to be in this
situation because they knew that they
were going to have to depend on the
americans to build this
space station and they did have one in
orbit called the mir at that time
but it was an antique it was about ready
to have to be thrown away so ultimately
what we found out was just let them
bluster
until they wore themselves down be very
firm on what we wanted to do and then at
the party afterwards and there was
always a party afterwards that's when
you started making
you know some friendships and some
common calls and that's that's how we
worked it out okay now now give me an
idea of the space station as it's
constructed now
you have
the the americans
and the russians they're up there at the
same time what what's the the layout of
the land up there i mean is it there's a
russian side an american side what is it
like up there
there is a russian side there's no
question about it essentially from what
i understand talking to some of the
american astronauts
the russians tend to keep to themselves
already a little bit over on their side
of the station
but there is some
some
obvious obviously common equipment
including a data processing
a system that the russians have on their
side that operates throughout the space
station primarily however
the russians in the last few years have
been
mostly
adding to the space station
or helping the space station out by
boosting it into a higher safer orbit
it's so huge
there are still enough air molecules
even at 200 miles to start slowing the
space station down so when they bring up
either a progress cargo craft or a soyuz
they'll attach it over
at the
on their side and then
before the progress or the soyuz
detaches they give the space station a
little boost and then they detach and go
on back to the earth or burn up in the
in the air like the progress does okay
so
but there is an awful lot of back and
forth between
the ground stations between mission
control and houston
and um their uh version of uh
called the soup to soup tsup
uh over in the uh in a suburb of moscow
there's a lot of interaction back and
forth uh between them
in this current conflict we're like
three weeks into this russian invasion
of ukraine
there has been tension with american
mark vanda high who's supposed to come
home march 30th nasa says that's going
to happen he'll come home on a soyuz so
we'll still be working with the russians
but dmitry ragozan who is the chief of
the russian federal space agency
hinted that you know what we could just
leave they put this video out looking
making it look like they leave they
abandoned mark vande high and they leave
it and and then threaten that the
station the uh could be out of orbit and
then fall on our heads
the reality of that what's the reality
of that
well regarding just doesn't make sense
he's been blustering around and
canceling contracts that he already had
to
launch commercial satellites and they
they obviously desperately need the
money over there in russia
but his blustering includes saying uh
well maybe we'll just withdraw entirely
from the international space station and
we won't bring your astronaut back and
blah blah and everybody knew that this
was just a big bluster on his part and
don't really understand why he's doing
this he seems to be separated from the
rest of his own agency because the
nasa nasa folks and uh russ cosmos
uh people the russian space agency are
working very very well still without any
hindrance whatsoever any change really
in the operations of the international
space station
forward from that
we do have spacex we have dragon
capsules they bring astronauts up into
the space station now they can
how much more do we need even to rely on
the russians for soyuz launches to get
there or get home
well we don't really need to rely on
them at all and i think i would be
willing to to guess that in the future
we might have maybe one or two more go
but no more uh we just can't deal with
russians anymore we can't trust them uh
based upon everything that's going on
and what records and who's after after
all the boss is saying
so it would be best for us to go ahead
and plan to
to carry our crews up on american uh
spacecraft so we not only have spacex
but we have uh boeing starliner coming
along eventually it will be ready how
much longer
is the international space station
supposed to be up there anyway
well uh just recently and it surprised
most of us to pay attention to to
the space program and space matters uh
just recently nasa announced that they
were going to extend the life of the
international space station to 2030. uh
most most folks thought that the end
would be around
2026. uh so
we're not exactly sure
why
that decision was made because
on
nasa's plate right now is the artemis
program which is going to require a huge
expenditure of funds and effort
and i'm not really sure that they have
enough personnel or money to operate
both the international space station and
artemis which is the return to the moon
program
which which
includes building another space station
called the gateway and all that's
supposed to be done in the next few
years
gateway is it
would it would replace it
what's different about the gateway
versus the current
space station
well gateway is as a
a mini space station that actually uh
operates in the vicinity of the moon so
it's not going to replace the
international space station in low earth
orbit and the reason for it is to have
some place for
the
american astronauts to
wait
for
the
hls
the spacex which is a uh a starship
that hasn't even flown yet to fly up to
the gateway pick up american astronauts
there and use
the human landing system hls
starship to land on the moon so
my gosh there's a huge amount of work
for nasa to make any of that happen
well if we
don't work with russia anymore would
that precipitate a faster conclusion to
the space station's life
i i you know
we've got to talk to our partners we've
got major partners we just can't do
things unilaterally we have signed a
treaty uh not only with russia and this
was in 1998 but with the europeans
through the european space agency uh
which includes the uk
uh and japan and canada and uh this is
we have uh treaty obligations before we
do anything we can't just walk away from
the space station without getting
other more agreements with
with our partners
whether we have the russians or not so
the japanese may continue to want to
operate their uh the gym module the
japanese experimental module
and the europeans have have their
laboratory up there too
they are they're keen and eager to keep
it going
so
nasa i mean just in terms of diplomacy
has an awful lot of work to do and an
awful lot on their plate right now but
again you don't see any drama bringing
mark vanderhi home i don't i don't and
i've talked to
the folks here at marshall space flight
center who operate the control
here and um their indications are that
there's they're working very very well
with their russian counterparts most of
whom they know by the way they've been
back and forth to russia they've been
back and forth here to huntsville and
down to houston
and uh so
that partnership is working very well at
that engineer uh technical level i just
don't see also
the russian
cosmonauts and american astronauts again
they're they are friends they have been
they visited each other's families they
probably die for each other so i don't
see
the russian cosmonauts being bullied so
much that they would leave their buddy
mark behind so
so i i see them coming home without any
problem
homer hickam former nasa engineer also
author of rocket boys don't blow
yourself up and also many other books
including novels homer thank you very
much for joining us
well my pleasure thank you for having me
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever-changing times you can rely
on fox news for hourly updates for the
very latest news and information on your
time listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts rate and review
the fox news rundown on apple podcasts
or wherever you listen it's time for
your fox news commentary
live
what's on your mind just when you
thought things could not get worse along
comes the very real possibility of a
downturn
thanks to biodynamics the war in ukraine
and an inept federal reserve
a year ago during a robust recovery such
a forecast would have seemed ludicrous
top wall street economist recently
conducted an informal pull of his firm's
clients to his surprise 100
thought the u.s would be in a recession
by next year
why such gloom
it starts with accelerating inflation
caused by out-of-control government
spending and measures taken by the biden
white house that kept workers on the
sidelines
inflation is also being fueled by
soaring energy prices thanks to lower
u.s production in the midst of reviving
growth and now the disruption to russian
oil exports
a note the four past recessions have
been preceded by sharp hikes in energy
prices
100 oil is a red flag to combat
spiraling prices the federal reserve
must begin raising rates aggressively
which will slow growth
after initially dismissing spiraling
inflation over the past year and then
blaming supply chains snafus and greedy
corporations the white house is now
saying russian president vladimir putin
is responsible
unfortunately for biden most voters
disagree
voters know that democrats signature
government spendathons have driven
40-year high inflation biden signed into
law the 1.9 trillion dollar american
rescue plan just three months after
congress passed a 900 billion dollar
package
it brought total covid related spending
to 5.7 trillion dollars
more than was spent fighting world war
ii
the arp exploded already strong demand
and led to shortages and inevitably
rising prices
simply stated it created too much money
chasing too few goods
soaring energy costs are also clearly a
major factor in the recent inflation
surge biden is blaming putin but voters
know that of the dollar 75 hike in
gasoline prices over the past year fully
one dollar predated the war in ukraine
one dollar per gallon which is robbing
americans of 400 million dollars every
single day because of that and many
other issues americans are becoming more
pessimistic
the university of michigan's consumer
sentiment index sank to the lowest level
in 11 years in february worse than
expected
considering the robust jobs market the
dismal reading is surprising but real
wages are down 2.6 percent over the past
year people know when they're falling
behind recession in 2023 is not yet the
consensus to be sure after all the
economy is still motoring ahead driven
by a 40 increase in the money supply
over the past two years rising nominal
wages and a near record low inventory to
sales ratio which means that even with
rising uncertainty many businesses will
continue to invest in restocking goods
but the odds of biden's recession are
rising fast
liz peake fox news
you've been contributor to the fox news
rundown
stay up to date by subscribing to this
podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
i'm guy benson join me weekdays at 3 p.m
eastern as we break down the biggest
stories of the day with some of the
biggest newsmakers and guests listen
live on the fox news app or get the free
podcast at guybensonshow.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes